je me rappelle comme enfin qu'un
policier m'avait dit si on se retrouve
en ce sens dans le caniveau
c'est en gros ce sera bien fait pour toi
[Musique]
ce que les gens disent comment vous êtes
tombé l'impression générale répond j'ai
glissé je pense que j'avais quand même
envie de d'expérimenter sexuellement pas
mal de choses et je sais que dès
l'adolescence je savais que j'avais la
capacité de baiser avec n'importe quel
mec donc du coup je me suis dit pourquoi
pas essayer quand je travaille dans la
rue donc vraiment tout début là je me
rappelle qu' il y avait des policiers
qui m'ont qui me contrôler et réguler
ans quand j'avais l'air pour vendre
d'être mineur donc du coup j'ai beaucoup
de contrôles mais je me rappelle pour
enfin qu'un policier m'avait dit si on
se retrouve en ce sens dans le caniveau
c'est en gros ce sera bien fait pour toi
ça renvoie tout de suite à l'idée qu' on
n'est pas des citoyens comme les autres
et qu'on mérite pas les mêmes
protections que les autres citoyens donc
avec vraiment aussi cette idée que
finalement la violence seraient
inhérentes au travail sexuel et que si
on continue travail sexuel pas
finalement on mérite cette violence je
fais quand même la distinction entre les
clients et les agresseurs qui se font
passer pour des clients pour pouvoir
mieux voler ou avoir des rapports
sexuels gratuitement les agresseurs
savent que on est encore une des rares
une des dernières profession qui a
beaucoup d'espèces
on a des espèces sur nous on n'est pas
protégé par la police
le traitement des plaintes est très
compliqué donc la fin majorité des cas
les gens ne portent pas plainte
donc on est vraiment des cibles idéales
pour les agresseurs l'impact majeur de
la pénalisation des clients c'est
vraiment une précarisation donc avec des
prix qui ont baissé un pouvoir de
négociation qui s'inversait donc c'est
vraiment maintenant les clients qui ont
vraiment tendance à imposer les
conditions donc au niveau de la
prévention des prix des places est de
même des comment dire au niveau de la
sécurité puisque on est obligé aussi de
peut-être de plus de mobilité ou en tout
cas moins de choix dans les sur leur
lieu de travail que tu as précarité
santé dégradation de la santé insécurité
gens c'est vraiment les trois 3 2 contre
3 conséquences majeures de cette loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment on est dans un système qui
favorise ces violences et je pense que
les politiques ont une lourde
responsabilité et je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils arrêtent de penser qu'ils peuvent
se dégager de toute responsabilité en
disant la violence est inhérente à le
sisto système professionnel comme il
l'appelle
non c'est eux qui ont les
responsabilités ces violences là et il y
en a il va falloir qu'il change la loi
parce que je pense que c'est une des
choses basiques est primordial à faire
puis si on est sérieux pour lutter
contre cette violence